angular momentum measures how much
something is rotating for a very brief
time a few physicists thought that spin
was a type of angular momentum that came
from the electrons spinning on their own
axes these days were pretty sure that
that isn't the case electrons aren't
actually spinning but spin is still
thought of as a type of angular momentum
it's referred to as intrinsic angular
momentum angular momentum of particle
just has without physically rotating the
idea always struck me as odd and the two
arguments I've heard for it seemed weak
the first is that in quantum mechanics
even though angular momentum and spin
don't obey all the same equations they
do both obey one particular one then
people claim that this equation defines
angular momentum hence spin is a type of
angular momentum I never understood why
this random equation was so important
the other argument is what we looked at
last time the stern-gerlach experiment
and similar there I thought the argument
was that charged particles that have
normal angular momentum act like magnets
particles with spin also act like
magnets so let's just say that they have
a type of angular momentum to an
intrinsic type I thought that that was
unnecessary couldn't you just say that
spin is an intrinsic magnetism instead
isn't that a simpler explanation in the
last video I asked you to research spin
for me which you did a brilliant job of
I did the homework too by reading a
bunch of things and I realized that I
was wrong about both these arguments
there is a very good reason that
suggests that this equation defines
angular momentum I'll explain why in the
next couple of videos but today I'll
talk about why I was wrong about the
stern-gerlach experiment the angular
momentum isn't just a useless PI product
it's actually pretty crucial and so
maybe spin is angular momentum the
mysterious stern-gerlach apparatus is
actually just a giant magnet but a
regular magnet wouldn't be enough
because if a little magnet was put into
this field
it would be equally pulled up and down
instead the top bit is made pointy
because that makes the South Pole
stronger so the magnet is now pulled
upward more if the magnet was pointing
downward this South Pole strongly repels
the little magnet South Pole
so it goes downwards so you can start to
see how this machine might measure
orientation it works fine for these two
orientations but here's the problem that
bothered me for weeks imagine I put it
in on its side what we want the machine
to do is not deflect magnet either way
that seems fine the magnet is equally
attracted and repelled from both sides
but you can see these forces are going
to twist the magnet they keep twisting
it until it's pointing in the upward
direction now the force on the magnet is
up this happens to any magnet pointing
at any angle it gets twisted to point up
so by this logic pretty much every
magnet should go straight upward the
stern-gerlach machine isn't supposed to
do this so what's going on it turns out
I was wrong this machine just doesn't
work for little bar magnets exactly for
this reason but it does work when you
have a charged particle moving in a
circle I was making a big mistake
because I thought that these two things
were essentially the same because their
magnetic fields are the same but the
particles going in loops have one extra
property that I completely neglected
they have angular momentum that comes
from their rotation we can represent
angular momentum with an arrow the
length of the arrow represents how big
the angular momentum is so if we rotate
the object faster the arrow is bigger
the arrow also has direction and this
represents the direction the object is
spinning the arrow is always
perpendicular to the plane the object is
rotating and the key thing about the
angular momentum is it doesn't like to
change so that means it's hard to speed
up or slow down the object and it's hard
to tilt it because either of those
things are going to change the arrow
going back to our situation if we have a
rotating object
we put it in a magnetic field just like
the bar magnet the magnetic field will
try and twist it but if it did get
twisted its angular momentum would
change and so unlike the bar magnet it's
going to resist that twisting and that
has a pretty unexpected consequence
instead of twisting this way its angular
momentum traces out a circle this is
called larmor precession if you want to
see the maps behind why this is I'll
explain that now otherwise skip the
explanation and I'll just tell you why
any of this matters for spin for this
explanation we need our classical
mechanics I'll do my best to explain
this but it took me ages to understand
this properly so don't panic if it's
confusing we need to introduce one more
technical word talk a talk is something
that twists an object in our case here
it's from the magnetic field just like
angular momentum though torque is a
vector and it's Direction is
perpendicular to the direction of
twisting the magnetic field is trying to
twist the angular momentum this way so
the torque is in this direction our
angular momentum is currently in this
direction and we want to know which way
it will be pointing in a very short time
later delta T so we use this equation
from classical mechanics the new angular
momentum equals the old one plus the
torque times delta T multiplying the
torque by delta T just makes it smaller
and then we add our old angular momentum
using vector addition the result is this
vector you can see how the angular
momentum has started to turn around this
circle but if you think about it the
magnetic field is still trying to twist
it but now in that direction so the new
torque is this way if we apply the rule
again the result is a vector even
further along and if we keep doing it we
can see that the angular momentum
processes this was so hard for me to
wrap my head around because this talk
wants to make the angular momentum point
up but it doesn't make it point up any
more than it was instead it makes it
spin in the other direction
so if you put this thing with angular
momentum into the stern-gerlach machine
it won't just flip up like the bar
magnet would in other words the
stern-gerlach machine only works if you
have angular momentum when you put a
particle with spin in the stern-gerlach
machine it does work and so by this
analogy they should have angular
momentum being magnetic is not enough
and so maybe it is fair to say that spin
is an intrinsic angular momentum but
then again all of this is just an
analogy from classical physics does
larmor precession even happen in quantum
mechanics actually it does and it's
pretty awesome say an electron is doing
this quantum mechanical larmor
precession if it's gone around once
you'd expect it to be in the same state
that it was in originally but it's not
you have to let it go around twice
before it's the same again before this
video ends I want to thank you all so
much for doing the research for me last
time I learned a lot and hopefully you
did too people told me about ideas I've
never heard of and recommended a whole
bunch of books too and so since that
last video I feel like my knowledge of
spin and quantum mechanics in general
has just increased a lot obviously I
want to do these research homeworks more
often but there's one big problem a lot
of the sources on this type of material
are really advanced and confusing so it
could have been difficult to read for a
lot of people how can we make sure that
everyone can participate in this sort of
homework if they want to and also I've
been thinking about other homework
assignments that I could give you do you
guys have any ideas on what you'd like
me to try now for this video is actual
homework I'm interested did you guys
find this videos argument convincing
should we call spin intrinsic angular
momentum is it weird to even try and
explain spin with classical ideas using
classical analogies is intrinsic angular
momentum and inherently meaningless
phrase anyway every time I ask these
sorts of questions I get a really
diverse set of opinions all well argued
so this one should be fun secondly I
mentioned that you can only
an electron back to its original state
by rotating it twice last time some
people commented that this isn't so
weird
that some classical things do this too
what do you think of this do you know
any examples finally for the classical
mechanics fans I explained why a
rotating thing in a stern-gerlach
machine doesn't just flip and point up
but now explain why the force that it
experiences is proportional to how much
it was pointing up to start with next
time I'm covering my favorite bit of all
of physics and so I'm really excited see
you soon